Netflix is the Witcher delivers on its
promise of high fantasy monster hunting
but it's not always easy to follow if
you made it to the end of the first
season and feel a little lost you're not
alone here's what you need to know even
though much more the final episode of
the witcher's first season is happening
in one more or less United timeline our
characters don't cross paths until the
very end
ciri spends the bulk of the episode with
a kindly commoner who wants to adopt
seriouser daughter
meanwhile Geralt begins the episode in
the same refugee camp that Cirie visited
in episode 2 where a local merchant is
clearing out dead bodies
Geralt defends the merchant from some
zombie like monsters but is wounded in
the process the merchant who happens to
be the commoners husband puts Geralt on
his cart and starts towing him to safety
yennefer whose adventure takes up most
of the episode makes a stand with other
mages at sodden where they fight to
defend the north from the nilfgaardian
army in the aftermath two Seiya
magically calls out for yennefer ciri
hears her and heads to the woods where
she meets Geralt for the first time she
asked the Witcher who yennefer is but
before he can answer the credits roll
why exactly did no Guard invade the
north raised sintra and turned sodden
into a massacre it's after more than
just ciri if you track nilfgaard history
over the witcher's different timelines
you'll actually see the story of a
humiliated nation that rises from the
ashes in order to restore its lost glory
early on before yennefer is ascension no
guard is a joke it's King Fergus wastes
the kingdom's money on frivolous
pursuits the brotherhood of sorcerers
hope that a court mage can help bring
Fergus under control
instead sometime around Geralt story in
episode 3 someone known as the usurper
organizes a rebellion overthrows Fergus
and takes the crown sometime after that
Fergus is son and murder reclaims the
nilfgaardian throne and sends his army
out to conquer the north
that's when Sentra burns and house Aden
becomes the site of the mages Last Stand
amazingly the mages managed to hold
sodden until help arrives from one of
the northern kingdoms you know that King
who arrives riding a white horse with an
army behind him
that's King full test of tomaría and if
that name sounds familiar it should
you've met him before king foltest is
the same King Geralt met at betrayer
moon he's the one who slept with his
sister who then died and gave birth to
the Striga that Geralt had
white bull test shows up thanks to Tris
miracle the mage assigned to his core to
fought at the Battle of sodden the King
still owes Tris for helping Geralt save
his daughter and it's just too bad that
he took a sweet time getting there much
more ends on a couple of cliffhangers
ciri and Geralt meet for the first time
and more importantly yennefer seems to
have disappeared after unleashing some
major magic on the nilfgaardian army
yennefer more or less vanishes the last
we hear of her to saya is worriedly
calling out her name given that much
more clearly establishes that using
powerful magic can kill a person it's
cause for alarm still don't worry too
much
yennefer is a major player in the books
and unless the show is planning to
deviate pretty radically from the source
material the sorceress should pop up in
season two and might take a little while
but we're almost certain she'll be there
while yennefer is defending the north
from milk guards advance Geralt spends
most of the season finale lying in the
back of a hay cart suffering poison
induced flashbacks to his past the
biggest revelation to come out of those
visions is at the Sena
a sorceress raised Geralt when he was a
small boy in fact while the show doesn't
make an entirely clear Witcher lore
dictates that the Sena is Geralt
biological mother the Sena didn't take
care of Geralt for long though when he
was still young she abandoned him
leaving him to be taken to care morin
where witcher's live in her train and
much more Geralt comes face to face with
his mother for the first time in decades
in a scene that could be magic or just a
hallucination whether the Sena actually
came to visit Geralt or nods you can
expect more details about the witcher's
childhood it's season 2 don't ask any
more questions or the answers will only
hurt us both
it's time to move on down the other
major figure introduced in Geralt
visions is vesemir after the Sena
disappears it's vesemir who comes to
little Geralt sate and garel utters his
name a few times during his poison
induced delirium The Witcher doesn't
explain who vesemir is but fans of the
franchise know him quite well like Daryl
vesemir is a Witcher he lives at the
Witcher stronghold Kerr Morin and is one
of the oldest and most respected members
of the fraternity thanks to a past
adventure gone awry vesemir rarely
leaves Kerr Morin however he's one of
the best instructors the witcher's have
and he functions as a de facto father
figure to Geralt in the books the show
will probably make a few changes to the
story but the season finale has already
put the basic pieces in place expect
vesemir to pop up during season two
ultimately the first season of The
Witcher is about three people trying to
find a family we don't know one until a
finale but the Geralt we meet at the
beginning of the show was abandoned by
his mother
yennefer is sold off by her foster
father and deprived of the ability to
have children series family is killed in
the very first episode each one of these
characters has the opportunity to find a
new family over the course of the season
and each one rejects it instead our
three heroes find comfort in each other
in the books the trio form a makeshift
family the show isn't quite there yet
but if you're paying attention it's very
clear where it's going check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you